c'est l'un des rares cantons à ne subir
aucune modification pour ce scrutin une
élection qui s'apparente à un duel de
poids tueur avec la présence de deux
mers le binôme socialiste voit se
présenter françois de ligne et maire de
guyancourt et conseiller général sortant
je vais prendre un exemple celui de
l'éducation puisque j'étais dans la
commission éducation et que j'étais
également au conseil départemental de
l'éducation nationale et j'ai agi pour
défendre le système public d'éducation
des exemples pour les moyens pour les
collèges les six collèges publics de
notre canton ou obtenu des moyens en
terme de travaux et de rénovation et
puis pour l'université j'ai obtenu le
schéma départemental pour les résidences
étudiantes
élu en 2008 dès le premier tour françois
de ligne et s'associe cette année à
sandrine grand gambe première secrétaire
fédérale du parti socialiste est
suppléante du mercredi en courtois aux
cantonales de 2008
le binôme conscient des difficultés
vécues par la gauche actuellement axe
principalement sa campagne sur l'action
sociale le logement et les déplacements
le conseil général s'occupe de la
question du handicap
là aussi il ya énormément de de
défaillance et il ya des dossiers
apporter pour éviter que des familles
soient obligés de voir leurs enfants
partis en belgique parce qu'il ya juste
pas les places nécessaires ici la
question des personnes âgées aussi je
pense qu'on a une population qui
vieillit on n'a pas assez pris en compte
le vieillissement de cette population
comme lors des dernières élections
départementales c'est michel laugier
maire de montigny qui se présente pour
la droite c'est vrai qu'on peut résumer
cette élection le maire de montigny
qu'entre le maire de guyancourt le
conseiller général sortant contre le
président de l'agglomération oui
effectivement c'est vrai que sur le
papier c'est cette bo rituel sauf que
déjà les plus grands duels puisque nous
sommes quatre à te sont plus 2 904 alors
maintenant je dire de tous est celui qui
aura
auprès des électeurs la confiance le
président de la casse qui s'associe
cette année avec laurence trochut
conseillère municipale d'opposition de
huy en cours avec pour principaux axes
le social la réussite scolaire et les
aménagements routiers mais axes de
campagne vont être en priorité tout le
domaine de la solidarité et de l'action
sociale
parce que je pense que vraiment à
l'échelle locale
être à l'écouté de tous ceux qui peuvent
nous confier leurs leurs besoins leurs
difficultés et bien c'est là qu'est le
renouveau de la politique dans ce canton
deux autres listes se présentent sylvain
grisons et eugénie la vigne pour le fn
europe ecologie les verts le front de
gauche s'associe avec olivier parent et
jean emilie germain le dren